If I talk about a European island that’s
divided in two, a former British colony where
you drive on the left and whose economy has
grown substantially in recent years, what
country would you think about?
I’m sure many would say... Ireland!
Right?
Well...sorry we won’t be looking at the
country of Guinness, the Harlings and green
leprechauns this time.
There’s another island, which isn’t talked
about much, that also fits that description.
Dear friends of VisualPolitik, in this video
we’re going to talk about Cyprus, a Mediterranean
island that is much hotter than Ireland but
which is also a territory split in two.
You see, this story isn’t that well-known.On
the island of Cyprus we can find two … different
states:
The Republic of Cyprus and the self-proclaimed
Turkish Republic of Northern Cyprus, which
is only recognized as a sovereign country
by Turkey.
So, while the southern part is fully integrated
within the European Union, the northern part
only interacts with Turkey’s political and
commercial networks.
So, as you can imagine, both sides have huge
political and economic differences.
Now, surely many of you may be wondering...
But how did this small Mediterranean island
become divided?
What is the Turkish Republic of Northern Cyprus?
We’ll answer these and many other questions
in this video.
So…
Listen up.
(CYPRUS, A CASUALTY OF THE GREAT EMPIRE)
This isn’t a unique case.
In many of the colonies of the former British
Empire, decolonization brought a lot of ethnic
and territorial problems.
This case is just another example.
Cyprus was granted to the United Kingdom as
a protectorate following an agreement with
the Ottoman Empire, at the end of the 19th
century.
It was given control of the island in gratitude
for the support the British had given to the
Ottomans in their war against Russia.
However, it wasn’t until the beginning of
World War I, in 1914, that the United Kingdom
formally declared Cyprus a colony.
Now, how was this colonial territory?
How did it end?
How did it affect Cypriot history?
Well... the truth is that the colonization
of Cyprus wasn’t plain sailing.
You see, many Cypriots, especially those of
Greek ethnicity, utterly rejected colonial
rule, and now that they had been freed from
the Ottoman Empire, they wanted to annex the
island to Greece, something known as Enosis.
And as you can imagine, the Cypriots of Turkish
origin didn’t like this idea much, as they
didn’t identify with Greece at all.
We’re talking about a confrontation that
fueled several revolts, which in some cases
had to be stifled by British forces.
Now, the biggest problem, the final confrontation
happened after they gained independence in
1960.
The confrontation for power between the Greek
community and the Turkish community escalated
to such a point that just three years after
independence, in 1963, violence broke out.
This situation led Turkey to threaten military
intervention in order to protect Turkish Cypriots.
Finally, the United States managed to defuse
the situation, but the battle had just begun.
After years of intermittent instability and
tense calm, finally in 1974, a controlled
coup d'etat from Athens overthrew Archbishop
Makarios III’s government and triggered,
just five days later, Turkey’s invasion
of Northern Cyprus.
And so, that’s how a division was drawn
which continues to this day, and which was
formally recognised in 1983 with the unilateral
creation of the State of the Turkish Republic
of Northern Cyprus, a country of just 300,000
inhabitants, which is only recognized by Turkey
and that 36 years after its independence doesn’t
even have a national anthem.
It also explains why, in the capital city
of this island, Nicosia, we can find a Berlin-style
wall that divides the city in two.
But...
Would you like to know how Cyprus handles
this national division today, and what remains
of the past tensions?
What would we find if we went to Nicosia,
Cyprus’s capital right now?
Well...
Listen up...
(NICOSIA, EUROPE’S LAST DIVIDED CAPITAL?)
Walking through some areas of Nicosia today
is the closest thing to walking through old
divided Berlin.
In many streets, especially those of the old
walled city, you can see barriers, fences
and walls made with barrels filled with concrete.
It’s the separation between the Greek Cypriot
and the Turkish Cypriot Nicosia.
A separation that has a completely abandoned
demilitarized strip that is controlled by
the UN, known as the Green Line.
(MAP)
This line extends from end to end across the
island, and is a Korean-style demilitarized
zone, with a maximum width of 7 kilometers,
and which accounts for 3% of the island's
entire territory.
But it’s in the capital, Nicosia, where
the Green Line is most apparent.
It is there that the worst clashes between
both communities took place during the second
half of the 20th century.
To give you an idea, in the capital, time
seems to have stopped along the strip.
And as a testament of that convulsive past,
you can see, for example, the former airport.
A facility that was completely abandoned in
1974 – yes, since the coup and the subsequent
Turkish invasion.
Now the only function of this airport is to
serve as a backdrop when a few tourists decide
to pose for pictures in the old waiting rooms
and in front of the corroded sixties-style
check-in desks, which seem to have been leftover
from an apocalyptic movie.
Of course, for those who love dark tourism,
it’s a “must see”, because you can get
some impressive images from that place.
And that's not all.
In the old workshops and car dealerships of
the Green Line in Nicosia, you can see old
imported and abandoned models that nobody
has touched since 1974.
There are also bars, restaurants and abandoned
houses where you can still see old bottles
of Coca-Cola on the table and gunshot blasts
on the facades.
But, we aren’t just talking about an abandoned
strip of land.
Even though the tensions have remained dormant
in recent years, the issue goes much deeper.
Allow me to explain, despite being in the
Mediterranean, the Turkish Republic of Northern
Cyprus is one of the most isolated places
on earth.
It hasn’t been recognized by any countries
and has been internationally sanctioned for
the past four decades.
From an international point of view, its only
access is Turkey, its inhabitants lack their
own passport and, any establishment with international
brands and franchises is prohibited.
(AUDIO: “At all levels, economically, socially
and politically, it’s as if we didn’t
exist.
[...] We live in a country where regular contact
with the rest of the world is severely compromised.”
Ozdil Nami, special Turkish Cypriot representative
in the negotiations for resolving the Cyprus
dispute)
In fact, it wasn’t until 2003, when some
restrictions were relieved, that the green
line was crossed for the first time in more
than 30 years.
Now, at this point, the question that crops
up is...
What can be done to resolve this?
Could this division end soon?
Well...
If you look at the history, it seems hard.
Even with the help of the Secretary General
of the United Nations who is determined to
achieve reunification.
António Guterres has set himself the challenge
of achieving an agreement to reunify Cyprus
under a bi-communal and bi-zonal federal system.
And to do so, 2020 could either be a turning
point or just another year on the already
long list of Cyprus’s diplomatic failures.
For now, the UN has set itself the objective
of resuming negotiations in mid-2020.
(AUDIO: UN hails 'frank' Cyprus talks, vows
to seek peace effort restart - Al Jazeera)
However, in recent years a new player has
emerged, further complicating the issue.
Listen up.
(REUNIFICATION, AN IMPOSSIBLE ROAD?)
When anything breaks, putting it back together
is very complicated.
And, of course, if we’re talking about countries,
it can be an almost impossible mission.
That’s exactly what’s happening in Cyprus.
You see, even though the tensions between
both communities have greatly decreased, there
are still difficult barriers to overcome.
What will happen to the Turkish troops, considering
that Turkish Cypriots basically depend on
them?
How will the issue of the properties seized
from Greek Cypriot owners be resolved?
How will both communities be politically organized
so that one isn’t under the other’s control?
How will the territory be distributed?
What will happen with social policy?
Will the south finance the development of
services and infrastructure in the much poorer
north?
And with all these questions comes a new geostrategic
problem, one that threatens to kill these
negotiations and which has a lot to do with
something we’ve already talked about here
on this channel.
Cyprus is currently involved at a commercial
and economic turning point that Turkey doesn’t
approve of.
And even though the Turkish Republic of Northern
Cyprus is, in theory, an independent country,
the truth is that Turkey rules Northern Cyprus’
interests by aligning them with theirs, especially
when it comes to international politics.
After all, it’s the only country that recognizes
this republic, while also maintaining more
than 30,000 soldiers deployed on the island.
The fact is that it’s here that we face
a new obstacle, in the shape of a long, thick
tube located under the sea.
We’re talking about the EastMed gas pipeline.
The EastMed is a pipeline whose construction
could begin very soon, which will allow Israel
to export natural gas directly to Europe by
2025.
Israel... and Cyprus, which has also begun
to exploit its gas reserves at sea.
And, as we’ve already discussed in a previous
video, Israel has managed to boost its gas
production, achieving very significant production
figures.
In fact, just a short time ago, on January
2nd, 2020, they took a giant step regarding
this project.
(AUDIO: Leaders From Israel, Cyprus, Greece
Sign EastMed Gas Pipe Deal - Bloomberg)
Now, the question is, why could this be a
problem when it comes to conversations about
Cypriot reunification?
Well, because this clashes directly with the
geostrategic and economic interests of Turkey,
which is where the gas pipeline that currently
conducts exported gas from the Middle East
to Europe flows.
This situation gives Turkey the power to control
the passage of a vital supply to a continent
that hasn’t been very friendly to the Turkish
regime in recent years.
You can imagine how this goes, right?
Well, if we add to this mix the fact that
it’s Israel, ISRAEL, who would benefit the
most from this project, then things get even
more complicated.
Because, lately Turkey and Israel are getting
on worse than Batman and the Joker.
So, if reunification was already a challenge,
this new confrontation between Turkey and
the Republic of Cyprus only looks to make
it much more complicated.
Anyway, this is how things stand in Cyprus
today.
But now it's your turn: Did you know about
the Turkish Republic of Northern Cyprus?
Do you think these two states should reunify
or should they maintain their independence?
Leave your answer in the comments.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe to see brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.